when you work with dwayne johnson and
was it 2006 on the gridiron gang
did you have any idea he would be the
star that he is today
well i'm not surprised that he became
the star that he is today
um the guy is he he goes in 150
on everything he does he doesn't do
anything half cocked
um his commitment to excellence i think
it comes from his upbringing
uh and also his you know he was an
accomplished
football player in college uh played
with the national champion uh
team with the miami hurricanes and then
obviously what he accomplished as a
wrestler and his humble beginnings and
if you know anything about him you know
huge disappointments going through
football the nfl and the cfl
and then having to start and beg vince
mcmahon for a job at you know these 150
a night barnyard wrestling tours that
they were doing
and you look at where he truly came from
and
and just his passion his devotion and
his his commitment to learning the craft
and making it as good as i think i think
there are those few people that you say
he can accomplish anything he wants
i i think that's somebody i'd put at the
top of the list absolutely
do you remember anything notable from
being on set with dwayne johnson
yeah i mean sure i mean you know it was
a memorable time and fortunately i
you know proud to say that we remained
good friends
um you know here we are 14 years later
um
still can call him a friend still in
touch
he's you know as i said he his
commitment to excellence is second to
none
he takes so much pride and you ever talk
about somebody who
when they talk to anybody it didn't
matter if it was the guy who was
cleaning the toilets
it didn't matter if it was an extra it
didn't matter if it was the director or
me
producer or anybody when when he talked
to you he was there 100 percent
it was all about this moment with that
whoever he talked to
and i think the most memorable time for
me when we were making the film was we
were about
two or three weeks in we were shooting
during the
summer it was probably may or june
and we were shooting up at the prison in
malibu where we actually
my father and i shot the documentary we
went back and shot the the scripted
piece with dwayne there
and he got really sick
he got a flu something when it was food
poisoning or what it's something
something happened and
you know it's one of those things you
know the medics were called you know
just it wasn't
he was it was just you know you're star
sick you get the medic there you have a
medic on set and they were checking his
his blood and it's this and that and and
it was like first thing he usually say
is look you know we're here for three
months dude you want to call he said no
no
no i got this he goes i just need i need
10 minutes let me just give me 10
minutes
let me hydrate let me let some of the
aspirin kick in let me
we'll do this and what was interesting
it was his first
real deep scene with one of the kids
where he was interacting with one of the
kids from the program
and i don't know if anybody remembers
the film it's a scene where he's
encounters the the samoan running back
junior
in the middle of the yard at night the
kid had a call because it was his
daughter's birthday and he was pissed
that he was missing his birthday
and dwayne wouldn't let him be part of
the football program because he had a
hair trigger all he did was fight
and spend all his time in solitary so
dwayne sit down you're not going to be
any part of the team so
what this scene was was the two of them
coming together
and this kid convincing dwayne that he
can be a part of the program and be a
productive part of it
and i knew at that moment
you know we've all seen people tough it
out but you want to talk about being
able to completely
block out what he was dealing with and
rise to the occasion or accept the
challenge which was the saying on
gridiron gang
he did it and i knew at that moment i
said god this guy
you know he he wasn't created we'll just
say that you know there's enough
created fabricated tough guys in
hollywood
or greats in hollywood and and i knew at
that moment this guy was genuine he was
sincere
he was passionate and you know went all
in
take us back to the documentary that you
did
how did that come about funny story
um we my father my stepmother and i had
done
a host of reality shows before the term
was
a term there were documentaries on
probated youth it started with desperate
passage back in 1986
then became made in voyage desperate
passage was with michael landon maiden
voyage with sharon glass then it was a
step apart with marlo thomas and then
you know eddie james almost had done a
few of them and they were just they had
got you know these wonderful great
actors to host
or narrate these documentaries about
probated youth that we did
and it was basically they were done to
show america the hearts cry of
troubled youth that they are still kids
that they weren't raised they were
basically
put out and often were raised by street
gangs or
you know by pimps and drug dealers and
that these these were still children
they were still human beings that
deserved a chance
and we learned over the years that a kid
didn't
care what you thought unless you unless
you knew you cared
and then once we broke through that some
remarkable things happened and we ended
up doing things about eight or nine
so we had done a slew of these and had a
lot of success and
a couple of studios that optioned a few
of them to be turned into scripted films
and my stepmom linda who i call mom but
um my mom was reading the la times and
there was a story in the metro section
about
one of the jails that we had done a lot
of filming at was starting
a football team within the confines of
the jail and the hope was
that these kids would be allowed to go
out and play against the straight
schools
and they started with an eight-man
football team or a seven-man team the
first
year and then the second year when we
heard about it and it finally made press
was they were they were gonna fill a
full team
so mom came into the office and was all
excited threw the thing down on my dad's
desk and said oh my god this is this is
a movie
my dad was like yeah yeah
we've done these and linda god bless her
mom she was like no no no no no
this is the one this is the one so she
pushed him pretty hard
so after a few days he called probation
and said hey it's lee how you doing we
want to come up we'd love to do a
documentary we saw the article in the la
times and we've been doing this with
probation at this point for
seven years we've had all the success
and done well
and they kind of laughed us off and said
yeah get in line
like what are you talking about well
ever since that article came out every
studio in hollywood wants to do it we're
engaging
you name the actor you name the producer
they're trying to negotiate the rights
this is
this is out of your wheelhouse guys you
know
so we kind of we're like that's too bad
that we got excited about it assuming it
was going to be ours and we lost it
so about three weeks went by
and the head of probation called my
father and said are you still interested
in doing the uh
the the story on the prison football
team and my father said well
why i thought you had hollywood's elite
yeah we we do and we have and
we got a quick quick crash course on
how hollywood does things and we all
decided we kind of like the way you guys
do things so if you'd like to do it the
rights are yours we'll see here they
start practicing three days
and we didn't have any money and uh
we uh we ended up just beg borrowing and
stealing some cameras and
got the funding after the fact we'd like
raced up to get it because i mean how do
you call somebody we need funding in
three days we just we kind of
knew what we could go to some of our
trusted investors from the past shows
but we just rolled the dice and grabbed
a couple cameras and sound and
a small crew of four of us is what it
usually was
and went up and shot and we made the
documentary
we got the funding and when i say the
funding i think it was probably two
hundred thousand dollars to
to make this documentary and what was
really funny
is in making it um you know
we covered the first game and what you
saw in the the film with the rock was a
direct lift i mean
basically jeff maguire our writer
watched the documentary and just wrote
what was there it's all there and it was
interesting because the kids had lost
their first game cried like babies
we all went our separate ways that was a
movie it was over as far as we were
concerned it was over and
my father was speaking uh for janet reno
who was the attorney general at the time
in atlanta
for a big fbi conference they wanted my
dad there because he understood so much
about the
youth of today and incarcerated youth
and they just kind of wanted to
understand from somebody who'd worked 20
years with these kids
kind of to hear his take on it not being
a clinical psych or a cop you know let's
let's hear somebody who's worked with
these kids different point of view
so my dad goes to atlanta with my mom
and they're gone and
it was like they've made a week out of
it because my uncle lived in florida and
they're going to spend time with them
i get this phone call from my father he
said hey uh what are you doing this
weekend and i was like
i'm just hanging out what's up he said
you know the documentary we did on the
film
uh with the football team i said of
course he said well those
little brats are playing for the state
championship i need you to get a couple
cameras i need you to go handle it and
then there's an awards banquet after
that
i need you to go deal with it i am stuck
in atlanta so
i had to scramble and get a couple of
great cameramen i think it was phillip
hearn and steve elkins
and chip brooks did sound and me
directing and we went out and shot
their championship game against
montclair prep where they lost 13 to
seven and uh and then the awards banquet
at the old sportsman's lodge right after
that
and then that was it and that's how it
came about
and uh nobody wanted it it was
interesting with all the success we
had nobody wanted it it sat
um was steve bell who had basically
given us anything we wanted at ktla and
tribune to launch our shows was no
longer there he had gone to start i
think
stars or encore so we were dealing with
the new regime at ktla and
tribune and they didn't really capture
the vision
and our agents at caa at the time
watched it and said that's a that's a
cute little
documentary and you know
my dad went back to get the vhs from the
projectionist at caa and he was wiping
his eyes he said i heard what he said
don't listen to a word
this is one of the most powerful things
i've ever seen you're going to do great
with this
and we finally got it on tv it won an
emmy for uh
i don't know what the heck it won for
but it was it was a big national emmy it
won my dad
and uh the day after it aired on tv
every studio but paramount called
to make a bid every a-list actor you can
imagine was calling i mean we went into
the office the next day there was you
know the thing ran out of tape
and the next week the phone just rang
off the hook you know it was everybody
trying to get the rights
so it was an incredible experience it
was a whirlwind
and then it took another 14 years to get
made
so can we can we have a condensed
version of those 14 years and why
do you think that's really nothing
okay why do you think that is well it
was easy i mean you know mark canton ran
the studio
uh if they had to have it because
everybody else wanted it they paid the
most and gave us the prettiest pitch
so jeff mcguire had just written the uh
in the line of fire with clint eastwood
and wolfgang
pedersen and got the academy award
nomination so he was our writer so
the film acquired two million and a half
i think two and a half million dollars
of
studio costs against it and then canton
was out he was fired
and the new regime came in and usually
what happens is all those films that
have been sitting around going to turn
around so they put gridiron in a
turnaround they're like yeah
you know whatever this is the old so
after uh 18 months of
development another reason i don't like
it the film sat with the two and a half
million dollar lien against it
and i don't think a month went by in 12
years
where somebody didn't call and say
what's going on with gridiron we'd love
to make it and we said hey there's a two
and a half million dollar fee against it
if you want to pay off sony
we can start from scratch and make the
movie and most people
would hang up before we were done with
the sentence it was like yeah not going
to happen
and uh um yeah so
14 years went by was from 1993 until
2005.
so what is that 12 years went by and
then
neil moritz who we had known years ago
when he first started his career with
juice and
stoned age we always had a respect for
each other and neil had become
obviously quite the producer with things
like fast and furious and a whole list
of other films
and just called it neil one day when i
heard
friday night lights was getting done and
they were going to make invincible they
were going to make
we are marshall they were making facing
the giants
we talked earlier about how hollywood
likes to keep doing the same thing
called neil and said do you want to make
red iron gang he said yes
let's do it and we had a meeting my
father and i went and saw neil
and he said do me a favor before you
come to my office shane
give me a list of cast he said this
thing has fallen on its face time and
time again it's about the cast we got to
make this thing cast right so
i spent the night putting together a
cast that i thought was going to change
the world and put the world
on its ear and while doing that my wife
girlfriend at the time val
said come in here i want you to see what
i'm watching on tv and i ignored her i
said i'm busy i'm
playing hollywood producer she came into
my office and she had tears pouring down
her face and said you need to you need
to come in here
she said i got your guy and i said come
on man really
she said come in well she was watching
the a e biography on the rock
and you know he had been arrested i
think a dozen times before his 18th
birthday
football saved him and how he thought he
was going to be an nfl player coming off
a championship college team and ended up
breaking his neck or rupturing all his
discs started over from nothing
and i watched
and was just fascinated and i literally
hit the delete button on the document on
my
on my computer went in to see neil the
next day
we caught up hadn't seen each other in
person in a while congratulated
him on all of his success and he said
great all right
where's your list and i said i didn't
make a list and you can see he deflated
and i said i got the i got the guy he
said
kind of needed a list what do you got
and i said the rock
and he thought for a minute and he
yelled to his assistant and said when's
my meeting with the rock and she said
you're having dinner with him tomorrow
he looked at me and he said i'm having
dinner with him tomorrow we're trying to
figure out something to do this could be
the one
he said get me a copy of the the
documentary you guys did on dvd
and let's find that original script that
mcguire wrote
15 years ago he was probably going to
need to be dusted off and modernized but
i want to go with that script just give
me the dvd and have it back here by
tomorrow i'm having dinner with him
tomorrow night
so i didn't have a dvd of gridiron gang
it was on vhs
so i found a place that converted it for
me in literally a half a day
sunset video ran it down to neal's
office just in time
and two days later neal called and said
duane wants to meet you guys and we
hung out at the jail and it was a great
experience and he he encountered the
kids and saw what we were doing and said
i commit let's make the movie and
14 years later we were rolling camera
and that was it
so that that meeting took place and then
he's he committed to it so take me on
why people were passing on it i'm
confused sorry
why were people passing on it within
that time would he hadn't reached the
level that he
is now at i'm confused nobody passed on
it once
once he signed on and went right to sony
we had a green light picture he was
very much in demand it was the
documentary that we struggled to get
seen
uh i see like doing the documentary and
having tremendous success i mean we had
already won
12 emmys and had 32 nominations
and nobody wanted to watch this one
which was kind of part of the same genre
sure as yeah and then finally we kind of
bartered a deal at ktla to get them to
put it on
and once it got on every studio wanted
it so we spent eight months
getting courted by everybody from disney
to sony to warner
to universal and then went with sony
and then canton developed it and then he
got fired so then everything just wanted
to turn around so it's that
we just we couldn't do anything with it
because there was a two million dollar
lien against it from sony
and what was really cool maybe this will
help clarify neil because of his
reputation
and his deals that he had at sony he was
like look the two and a half million
dollars they're claiming needs to be
paid back he goes that was 14 years ago
that money's been written off it's done
it's gone it's a new regime
i will deal with that and neil went in
and talked to amy pascal who
who captured the vision of the project
he was very excited about it and said
all right let's wait the two and a half
let's let's put a new let's put this
back on a fast track
and you know get a start we want we're
excited about let's do it
fortunately they were excited about
dwayne and we were rolling
he had to go shoot a film i think it was
doom
or the game plan and then i think it was
doom and then as soon as he got back we
started ours immediately
and then off we went and then what was
the reception once the
the narrative version was finished once
the film came out it did very well it
was frustrating because we finished it
in uh i think it was oh i want to say oh
five or
six and in september we were supposed to
come out
during the super bowl like build up to
the super bowl we wanted to give him
that football movie
and at the last minute sony decided yeah
we're going to push it another nine
months we'll come out in september
so it's like ah it's only been 13 years
what's another nine months
film came out it went number one did
very well it was number one for two
weeks
um it did well i think the fact that
there were three other football movies
out like invincible and we are marshall
and
facing the giants didn't help us but
it's still i think it did 30 or 38
million domestic in the box office
one thing that you don't hear about was
we were very fortunate with home video
sony created blu-ray as we all know and
there was a race between two mediums it
was blu-ray and another
home hi-def system i don't remember what
it was
and sony decided when they launched
blu-ray they were going to do it on two
films they did spider-man 2
and they did gridiron so what happened
is this gridiron came back and duane had
become such a big star during that time
the dvd and what little vhs sales were
were very very strong and then when they
recycled it for blu-ray why it was still
relevant
it more than doubled again so it had
this extra
boost that nobody expected which was
really special
so yeah that was that was gridiron it
did well it was fun and you know
it's nice to to have that
that in my resume and i don't mean that
it's it's you know
a career that's now 48 years going it's
nice to have had the number one
blockbuster
and it gives me we talked about chasing
that success i had as a 16 year old it
gave me that validation it
hit 30 37 36
and it it it really reminds me
everything's okay you know maybe every
10 15 years i'll have one
but maybe i won't again but it's okay i
i slayed the dragon and i can just move
forward and be comfortable with what i
do
and you had some people give you advice
as well that had also had success
early in life who who kind of like put
things in perspective
i know i was very very fortunate you
know with some of the the people that i
had run with or worked with or
befriended over the years you know
people that come to mind or people like
charlie sheen or brett michaels
uh you know there's the singer from
poison obviously rock of love celebrity
apprentice everybody knows
brat now uh from all different different
places
and brett and i have been best friends
since probably 93 or 94.
and here's a guy who had tremendous
success came from very humble beginnings
you know him and
him and other guys from poison jumped
into vandro from harrisburg pennsylvania
to l.a lived in an abandoned warehouse
or an abandoned laundromat for three
years
trying to make it and they had in the
80s and 90s had so much success
and then the music styles changed and
talk about a guy who was able to
reinvent himself
you know brett's had to reinvent himself
three times and he's done well every
time
and the one thing he taught me was
the cool thing is you know when he had
every rose has its thorn was his number
one hit so we
we kind of joked about i had my gridiron
he had his every rose it was kind of
funny when that finally happened
and he said here's the cool thing about
that nobody can ever take it away from
you
he goes there will be another 52 movies
this year that'll go number one
he goes that's fine but you still win
number one
and i never forgot that i never wore
that
conceitedly or with arrogance but it was
it gave me
the affirmation that i think so many
artists you know you want that and that
that helped um but he always gave me the
greatest advice he always said
um no one to get off the merry-go-round
you know we talked about that you know
getting off the merry-go-round at the
right time there's people that jump off
it too soon and it's still moving too
fast
and that's not good you know you think
about getting off a merry-go-round too
fast it'll kill you
and then there's the people that hang on
it too long and it comes to a stop
and people are waiting for you to get
off he said what you have to do is
figure out
how to ride certain moments of your
career and know
when to step away and it's never
easy you know when i say that i talk
about it film that you have a film that
does well
you can you can i'll use a very generic
term you can milk that
as long as you think you can but you try
not to over milk it
you try not to hinge your your future on
it you realize hey we were fortunate we
were blessed
we had a moment in time that nobody can
take from us
and there are going to be 51 other
number one movies this year so we need
to get moving and let the next people
come in and do what they need to do and
enjoy the moment and let's go on and go
back to work
so i've had some good advice with some
people in my life that have kind of been
that done there
i think that you know been very helpful
to me why not give up on the project
earlier
10 years in you're talking about giving
it up why it was sitting at sony
well we did because it was in turn
around and i didn't have two and a half
million dollars laying around with
accruing interest to
pay them off to get it back the one
thing that always gave us hope
was as i said i don't think a month went
by in 12 years where somebody
called and said hey what's going on
there was actually a time where peter
gruber called and said um
i know you've got your your deal with
sony that's got to be paid off i used to
be head of sony
i may be able to make that work i really
would like to try to make this into
something so we we did a deal with
uh with mandalay peter guber uh before
we ended up making it with neil
um there were a few people that that
would try to do some creative
so when you have a project and it's it's
generating that interest for so long
with people with that kind of juice you
never want to throw that away you know
we talked earlier about what's a good
script what's a good story what can you
use to get a foothold in this industry
well when you have a product and you've
got the peter goobers or the neil
moritzes
or the joe roths or the bobby neumeyer's
calling you on a regular basis saying
what's going on man let's you know
well okay there's something there you
don't just bury it
you can't you can't so i think there was
always the hope that it would get done
one day i think my dad and i had always
kind of said you know one day maybe
something will come along
maybe we'll have success somewhere else
enough where we can
buy out that two million and get it done
you know
um but it all worked out
and so when you filmed at the
sportsman's lodge both schools were
there right for this dinner no
this was all for the kids oh okay it's
all for the mustangs
interesting yeah and i don't think it
was a sportsman's lodge it was
it was a shh it was it's where
it's where um there's a sushi spot there
right now it's an all-you-can-eat sushi
place off wineca
and tampa across from the ash it used to
be called the smorgasbord inn
it was a sports banquet lodge similar to
sportsman's lodge but it wasn't so
you'd have to put that in but it's so
funny i just say sportsman's lodge
because everybody knows it but it was
like the swedish inn or something like
that
okay yeah it was it was the parents and
the kids and sadly there was only a few
parents
you know we had 48 kids on the team and
i think eight parents showed up
it was tragic i'm sad that's just that's
the way it is
you